so we just started a show on collider
called collider fyc where we get to
celebrate everything that we're going to
be talking about for the next couple of
months and one of the topics of
conversation we often have with the
changing voting Academy and just all the
different types of movies that are
getting Oscar consideration now is what
does it mean to be an oscar movie so I
wanted to pose that question to both of
you for you personally what does it mean
to be an Oscar movie I think it's it's
it's a film that that I think holds
together from beginning to end I think
it has to have it's all starts with the
script I think it has to have terrific
direction and and really good
performances but I think I think that's
changing what an Oscar movie is what
what people view that to be I think that
was one thing in the 80s I think or
going back to the seventies a different
thing in the 80s it's developed into
something else in the nineties and now
we're at where we're at with with
content being very different the
experience where people expect is very
different than available technology and
all that so there's just there's a lot
of things to consider but the main thing
the film has to do was be good I would
agree I think it I mean if if there's
some talk about a movie that it's coming
out that you're in like Green Book and
some people oh you know and this could
go all the way this could be nominee for
the screenplay and for this and for that
and whether that happens or not it just
means people like it for some reason
they like it for whatever personal
reason they're drawn to it they think it
has a chance to be light and maybe
seeing more than once and stay in
people's memories so that's all good
what if we don't get anything in that
regard it doesn't mean I still won't
think it's a great movie
something that crossed my mind while I
was watching this about the shooting
process is how many key moments in this
movie take place in a car where you're
not even sitting next to each other it's
one in the front one in the back so what
kind of shooting challenges do you have
when you can't make eye
like that also just with I guess I would
call this blocking when you're
constantly like Tony eyes on the road do
you just have to memorize when all that
happens yeah yeah yeah I mean he's
listening he's watching he's he's it
doesn't matter if he's in the middle of
a sentence or not the moment that I turn
around he's being in character it's like
I don't want you to turn around you're
driving the car look forward so it's you
know it's give and take but it is really
listening and that but it could be
really boring to have two guys on my car
frankly I mean how well-written the
dialogue is unless you're connecting
unless you're really reacting in the
moment from take to take to the what the
other guys doing and that's fun that's
really playing it since I mean it's not
only better for the movie but it's more
enjoyable process because then you
you've done a day's work or you've done
a scene maybe a whole bunch of times
from different angles but you're like
each so that wasn't even better that
moment was better than that one and so
you're excited about your imagining what
the director is gonna be doing he's
gonna be piecing this together I sing I
think he has all the pieces to make that
scene work just because that last take
was great for one year did brace well
when you said eyes on the road it was
like you were a little more strict not
too strict but it was perfect at that
point you know it also but just the
process of filming it that way I think
it I think it actually served to to be
something that was an advantage for us
because sometimes you take one of the
senses away the other ones improve right
you know here there's a rear view but
the camera was there so we didn't even
see him yeah we weren't working with him
in a mirror yeah we're not
didn't see me in the mirror right so
we're not seeing each other I'm speaking
basically to the back of his head and
he's looking out the window he saw that
the type of listening goes beyond just
hearing that you're sort of listening
and reading with your entire body and
being and so once you do that for a week
to start the film in a car when you get
out of that car and you're actually
sitting or standing across from each
other and having a conversation I think
it did something to improve our art
chemistry yeah so the violence in it and
then when yeah we got into the to each
other's voice yes
you